un sit in devant l'université d'alger
depuis bientôt deux mois
ces étudiants occupent leurs facultés
mais ne vont plus en cours
une grève qui touche tout le pays chaque
jour les étudiants ici se réunissent
pour faire le point et préparer les
actions à venir pour demain feriel
beltràn y étudie les mathématiques
elle a 21 ans et comme tous ses amis
grévistes elle n'a connu qu'un seul
président abdelaziz bouteflika
en sortant en masse dans les rues chaque
semaine depuis l'arrêt février les
étudiants ont mobilisé la population est
poussée le vieux président à la
démission
mais pour feriel le combat est loin
d'être terminé
ce qui me dérange moi personnellement
c'est que des gens s'enrichissent et
prennent le pouvoir alors qu'ils n'ont
pas été élus et que à chaque ils sont
tous malhonnête et cherchent à
s'enrichir au détriment du peuple taux
de chômage élevé sentiment d'un horizon
bouché
une situation qui a poussé beaucoup de
jeunes algériens à s'exiler presque tous
ici ont un frère une soeur un oncle
partis à l'étranger mais feriel et ses
amis ont choisi de rester et de lutter
quand on est petit on veut d'être une
princesse petro en effet en grandissant
à nos rêves
change mais maintenant oui je rêve mon
seul rêve c'est que l'algérie soit
regagne sa liberté
mon grand baron ils ont ramené à
l'indépendance non c'est maintenant
c'est à nous de trouver la liberté ça ne
doit pas venir la liberté en à jean
philippe lellouche rennie on discute
souvent de politique malgré qu'on était
contre encore le quatrième mandat on
était contre et ont ils dit berbère et
opposant depuis ses années d'étudiant
omar a fait partie de tous les
soulèvements aujourd'hui il se réjouit
de voir sa fille prendre le relais et
lui souhaite de réussir là où sa
génération a échoué je voudrais pour mes
enfants je voudrais au nom de gerry
nouvelle gérer que qu'ils construiront
eux mêmes disons qu'on va les orienter
les guider les aider mais saturn a une
longueur d'avancé sur nous à l'image de
tout le pays
la contestation chez les bills où sera
ni a servi de pont entre les générations
sortir en famille c c
exceptionnel magnifique et si elle sort
manifesté plusieurs fois par semaine
feriel attend avec impatience les
vendredis où se retrouvent dans la rue
tous ses amis toute sa famille oui c'est
une affaire de famille on s'est tu
pendant des années lancé dit on s'est
promis de ne plus se taire et de ne plus
laisser les choses se faire
une famille qui semble s'être élargi
depuis quelques semaines à tout le pays
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
alger
[Applaudissements]